let's talk about the American election
one more time and hopefully this could
be one of the last times I have to talk
about Donald Trump
but there's something fascinating
happening the evangelical vote still
overwhelmingly supports Donald Trump
despite everything despite his his
repugnance despite his language which I
don't fault him for because actually I
cussed probably more than Donald Trump
so but you know for evangelicals this is
a big deal right he presents himself in
a way that's anything but consistent
with what they teach and what they are
ostensibly participating in American
politics for if you are in American
politics to bring a sense of morality or
your definition of morality to the
American conversation how in the hell do
you vote for somebody like Donald Trump
well the evangelicals have been
answering that in a resounding way these
are a series of images that were shared
by Sarah Posner of Mother Jones and the
Washington Post on Twitter and I thought
that it was really revealing extremely
revealing in a survey from the
Washington Post ABC News poll from
October 10th to the 13th so last week
overall do you have a favorable or
unfavorable impression of Donald Trump
white evangelical Protestants have an
oval I mean they're just they're leaving
the batch not many people have a
favorable view of Donald Trump but 59%
of white evangelical Protestants do
let's go to the next image among
registered voters Trump said that the
debate that if he were in charge of the
law Clinton would be in jail 68% of
white evangelical support that idea of
jailing Hillary Clinton let's keep going
do you think Hillary Clinton is
qualified to serve as president white
evangelical Protestants say 29 percent
say no white non evangelical Protestants
54 percent say no do you think Donald
Trump is qualified to serve as president
of course the white evangelical
Protestants 67 percent say that he is
qualified let's keep going do you think
that Donald Trump is honest and
trustworthy
61% of white evangelical Protestants say
yes and the white non Avenger not white
non evangelical Protestants 44% say yes
do you think Donald Trump has a strong
moral character or not I mean okay so
this is a little less this is 44% 44%
say yes of white evangelicals and white
not even Jellicle Protestants 37% that's
still a ridiculous amount Pat
considering everything that Donald Trump
shows us is there any more after this do
you think Donald Trump views reflect the
core of the Republican Party white
evangelicals lead the bunch keep going
this is the one there's a videotape
recorded 11 years ago in which Trump
talks about his sexual advances towards
women given what you have heard or read
about it do you do Trump's comment make
on the tape make you more or less likely
to vote for him
more likely two percent less likely 22
percent but 76 percent of evangelical
Protestants say that there is no
difference Pat what the heck do you do
with a group of people who say that
their sole participation in American
politics is to make sure that sexual
morality above everything else is a
cornerstone in the American democracy
not just sexual morality but sexual
morality as defined by the Bible is a
cornerstone in American politics but
they have after the fact stayed by
Donald Trump I mean I think there's this
whole idea and the evangelical religion
and community of free birth and
redemption right so they're just willing
to excuse him for whatever he's he's
said and done yeah yeah so two things
one I mean I come from that I come from
a similar community the the black
Baptist Christian Liberation Theology
it's different in the sense that well
anyway there's a lot of differences but
we do believe in that Redemption thing
here's the thing about Redemption Pat is
you have to actually be sorry for what
you've done you have to actually not not
just save face and try to get out of a
situation but you have to actually
believe what you did was wrong
Donald Trump has shown no indication
that he is legitimately sorry about this
because no
owner then he apologized for it he
rolled out the four women who were
accusers of Bill Clinton as as a way of
saying I know you are but what am I so
he not only has he not shown any
contrition what we call it in the
religious circles but he's actually has
gone even further to show everyone that
he has no remorse here's other thing if
you and this is a problem with the the
community as a whole if you can decide
and pick and choose what you're going to
redeem us what's redeemable and what's
not what people can be forgiven for what
this is how you get the Catholic priests
who are routinely forgiven for their
transgressions for their rape of young
boys and then you get no forgiveness for
someone who wants to get an abortion
because they can't afford to pay for a
child throughout their entire life right
it's like the selective morality that is
problematic for evangelical evangelicals
and this election has laid bare just how
empty how fraudulent this entire
marriage between evangelical voters and
the Republican Party has been it's never
been about morality man it's always been
about how do we get political and
economic power and the religious
community found that we can get it so
long as we're delivering millions of
religious voters to the Republican Party
and they are staying by their man no
matter how poorly it looks on their
entire faith you were saying something
earlier about Mormons are actually the
ones that are rejecting we've been
following the Mormon population in Utah
especially and Trump's numbers are far
lower than Mitt Romney's were four years
ago right and I will say this too I mean
the Republican Party for the past what
40 years has been practicing the
Southern Strategy yep just trying to
coalesce white voters overwhelmingly to
the point where they'll win the election
yeah the way that the demographics are
shifting now that's just not enough
there's you have to win over blacks and
Latinos and and just going for the
southern whites is it not enough to put
you over the edge anymore yeah I mean
and it really it really boils down to
what a guy that I like to read Jim I
think his name is Jim Moore
I forgive me if I read him a lot but I
can't remember his name but he's
actually the president of sojourners
which is like a really progressive
Christian organ outfit one of the things
he said is like this election is really
determining whether or not
evangelicals white evangelicals are more
evangelical or are they more white which
one takes precedent and this is panning
out to be they're clinging to their
whiteness as well as their this is this
isn't even conservatism I mean I think
anybody in their right mind like I think
conservatism isn't an enactment of
American Progress but Donald Trump is
not a conservative so not only is he not
a conservative he doesn't even know what
2nd Corinthians is he calls it 2
corinthians i mean he is the epitome of
everything every Sunday school teacher
always told you to avoid and not become
and yet you saw a poll after poll after
poll the evangelicals have aligned with
him and this is really this is really
going to be a blot a stain on them for
generations to come because they were
the few the few groups they were the one
of the few groups that stayed in support
of Donald Trump despite all of the
things that he's done that suggests that
he should be avoided at all cost and you
know what I think is simply because the
people like ralph reed people like tony
perkins and all of these Jerry Falwell
Jr of Liberty Lou University they are
all trying to maintain their control on
political power and the only way they
can do that is by standing by Donald
Trump